Welcome to my office.
You told me you were a 911 operator.
Yeah, I lied.
I'm a full-service fantasy provider.
All I need is someone to help me
clean up, be my bodyguard.
You know, like the Kevin Costner
to my Whitney Houston.
Kevin Costner gets shot at the end.
-Do you trust me?
-How much?
OK.
So, tell me about your friend,
the dominatrix.
We were, like, in love once.
Like a friend, sort of weird,
codependent love.
-It's complicated.
-Toodles!
Tiff! Mother...
Everyone thinks dom work
is just about sex work.
Grad school waits for no dominatrix.
It's really just liberation from shame.
What brings you in today?
Oh, you know, it's actually...
It's not for me.
It's... for... my...
I'm sorry, I didn't--
It's for my hus... my...
It's for my husband!
I'm not cut out
for what just happened in there.
You're braver than you think.
Yep.
What you do with me, that is free.
How come you never tell me anything?
Because if I told you
what we were going to do before we did,
then you wouldn't do it.
Hey.